el gobierno de Estados Unidos emitió un
comunicado de alerta mayor de violencia
antes de las elecciones de mitad de
término impulsadas por un aumento en el
extremismo doméstico esto según un
documento publicado conjuntamente por el
FBI el departamento de seguridad
nacional y la policía del Capitolio y
también el Centro Nacional de contra
terrorismo en este comunicado se dice
que los objetivos potenciales de esta
alerta mayor de violencia son candidatos
que se postulan a cargos públicos
funcionarios electorales personas que
participan en eventos políticos y
representantes de partidos así también
como minorías a raciales y religiosas
según los oficiales de inteligencia La
amenaza más posible antes del día de las
elecciones vendrá de delincuentes
solitarios o lobos solitarios que
aprovechaban aprovecharán los problemas
relacionados con las elecciones para
justificar la violencia de hecho estos
agentes del gobierno agregan que muchas
de las personas aún amplifican estas
narrativas falsas de fraude electoral
que se remontan al 2020 el informe se
emitió precisamente el día en que el
esposo de la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes Nancy pelosi fue atacado
violentamente por un hombre que entró a
la residencia a la congresista en San
Francisco gritando donde está Nancy
Dónde está Nancy pelosi el viernes
También el departamento de justicia de
Estados Unidos anunció que un hombre de
Pensilvania había sido declarado
culpable de múltiples amenazas por hacer
múltiples amenazas de muerte contra
congresistas